[موسيقى]
العالم فريقين فريق يقرض واخر يقترب وما
على المقترض الا ان ينصع لشروط المخرج
صراع بدا ولن ينتهي بسهوله
البيئه الحاليه اقتصاديا البيئه غير امنه
الاساس في قمه في الواقع انه بعض المفعول
به يريدون التملص والتخلص من التمرد على
ترتب على دقيق في النهايه كلنا عارفين ولو
انكر المنكرون اذا حبيت جمله واحده تفكيك
اوصال الزراعه المصريه
يديك عمر صعبه وعمر صعبه دي يعني نبوسه
ايدينا وش وظهر
الكل يعيش ويعاني هيمنه عمله واحده اللي
هي الدولار الامريكي شكل من اشكال
العبوديه الاقتصاديه في حقيقه الامر يعني
لانه الولايات المتحده عايشه على عرق
الاخرين
مساء الخير على حضراتكم انا النهارده معي
مفاجاه مفاجاه ساره ليا جدا لانه استاذي
الدكتور جوده عبد الخالق وافقه وشرفنا
اليوم
بعد الحاح لشهور وفي خلال الشهور الماضيه
دي كنت بحاول اقنع استاذي انه يجد لنا
وقتا في جدوله المزدحم لتسجيل مجموعه
حلقات عنوان والرئيسي افكار الاستاذ
فكره الحلقات اللي اتمنى ان تكون هذه
الحلقه باكورتها واول جزء فيها هو ان نطلع
على افكار الاستاذ الدكتور جوده عبد الخال
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه واراء اللي تكورت
على مدار سنوات طويله عامره يعني بالفكر
والافكار منذ ان تخرج طالب النابها في
كليه الاقتصاد والعلوم السياسيه
1965 وخلال السنوات الماضيه دي كان ليه
اسهامات عظيمه في الاقتصاد وفي السياسه
على المستوى الاكاديمي وعلى المستوى
السياسي والحزبي باختصار هدف الحلقات دي
ان نعرف كيف يرى الاستاذ العالم وعندما
يرى الاستاذ العالم يساعدنا في ان نراه
ايضا بشكل افضل ومختلف مساء الخير معالي
الدكتور مساء النور ليك اقول لك سيد كده
وبالساده المشاهدين انا الحقيقه متطلع
للجهاز السلسله جدا
وانا واثق ان انا اطلع منها بشيء ينعكس
على كثير من اللي هعمله بعد كده باذن الله
بس ارجو ان المشاهدين ربنا يخليك ربنا انا
كان تفكيري انه ده موضوع كبير لانه ما شاء
الله اسهامات حضرتك كتيره في الاقتصاد
والسياسه والفلسفه فكان تقديري لو بدانا
من نقطه انطلاق وهو تشخيصك للازمه
الاقتصاديه عالميا اولا ثم محليا
فمنها ممكن نبدا حضرتك شايف المساله ازاي
ونناقش حضرتك في افكارك نبدا بالازمه
الاقتصاديه الحاليه يعني هو
ناطق اساسيه في الموضوع
ونحن نتابع الطرح المحلي للمساله انه
اوجعني الاقتصاديه ليست من صنع ايدينا
انما هذا فيضن انجاز تعبير فايض
او نتاج لما يحدث في الخارج هذه الرؤيه ان
انا الخارج فاعل وانا مفعول به
انا يعني
عايز افندها واتوقف انها بس عشان ده يحصل
لازم نفهم الخارج هنا معناه ايه كويس كده
احنا بنتكلم على العالم حاليا بعد حوالي
30 سنه من انطلاق صايحه كبرى جدا
بعبر عنها بكلمتين ثلاث كلمات حي على
العولمه ما معنى العولمه معناها يعني
تطبيق ابداعات التكنولوجيا انجاز التعبير
لاسقاط الحواجز
بين الاماكن فيصبو عندك فضاء واحد في كل
اتجاه
واعاده تعريف الزمن زمان لو رجعنا مثلا كم
الف سنه
كنا نتكلم عن القرن وبعديه قرن وبعدين بقى
تحت القرن عقد من الزمان دلوقتي احنا
بنتكلم على فهمتو ثانيه طبعا
ده المقصود بانه يعني اعاده تعريف الزمان
والمكان
فطبعا هنا
لا يجوز ان ننظر الى العالم رغم هذا
التداخل الشديد على انه كل متجانس انما هو
خليط
لكن خليط لوبيا لها منطق معين ودي نقطه
يعني عايز اتوقف عندها في الفاعل والمفعول
به في الالم
هناك صراع يعني
ظاهر احيانا
ومستتر كثيرا بين المهيمن ومن يسعى الى
زعزعه وزحزحته
يعني طبعا عايز اتوقف عن
فتره ما بين الحربين
تحديدا الحرب العالميه الاولى والحرب
العالميه
الاولى معروف بدات 1914 وانتهت 1918 من
1919 لغايه 39 له تاريخ اندلاع هتتكلم على
20 سنه 20 سنه الحقيقه يعني في رايي لم
تاخذ حقها من الدراسه والتمحيص
واستيعاب دروسها فانا عايز الشير الى هذه
الفتره الفتره انتقاليه
كان فيها التمهيد
لزحزحه بريطانيا العظمى عن عرش العالم
بواسطه الولايات المتحده واحلال ولايات
المتحده محلها
الاقصى دين كتير يقول لك اه صراع على
الاسواق وغزو افريقيا ماشي كل الكلام اللي
كان فيه الجوهر انت بتتكلم مع صراع بين
الجالس على عرش
العالمى
امبراطيه لا تغرب عن الشمس كما نعرف الاسد
البريطاني كل المفردات اللي نعرفه في
القاموس السياسي
فهنا هذه الفتره اقتصاديا
كان من خصائصها الاتي
انه
العالم تخلى عن
قاعده الذهب
ولم ينجح في الوصول الى اساس اخر لكي
تستند اليه العملات فحصل فوضى نقليه كبيره
جدا في فتره 199 فوضى نقليه تشبه الى حد
كبير الفوضى النقديه التي نعيشها الان
بمعنى الحاصل في اسواق العملات وحركه
البورصات وايضا التجاره الدوليه
في المستتر كان بين القوى
الموجوده والسعيات اللي زاحتها كان في
مجال السعي لاقتناص الاسواق ومن هنا كانت
موجه تانيه للسيطره على افريقيا
باليات جديده في الموضوع
انما التغيير من نظام اللي هو كان موجود
حتى اندلاع الحرب العالميه التانيه
ونظام جديد اللي هو وجد بعد انتهاء الحرب
يعني
ايوه مزبوط
يحتاج الى زلزال عرفت يعني بيوت مستدعيه
ولكن البيت يفضل وقع طالما الدنيا مسلمه
يحصل هزه كبيره
فانهار النظام اللي كان موجود قبل قبل
الحرب العالميه طبعا الحرب كانت عنصر مهم
جدا في العمليه دي ادتنا هذه الهزه
العنيفه زلزله بريطانيا العظمى لان نفسها
محتاجه الى نجده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه للبقاء
كان تحدي وجودي بالنسبه لها وده في حد
ذاته رمزيا
كبير ولكن عمليا كان بمؤشرات الاقتصاد
والقوه العسكريه
والسياسيه
بدات دوله بريطانيا العظمى تدل وتحل محلها
دوله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كويس
احنا حاليا بقى في المرحله دي احنا بنتكلم
على اللي بيحصل في العالم تقريبا نعيش
فتره
تناظر وتذكرنا بفتره ما بين الحربيه
الامريكين الاولى والايه والثانيه وعلينا
ان نعود الى تفصيلات هذه الفتره وما حدث
فيها
للابحار الامن لو انا بتكلم على الواضح في
مصر حاليا هو عايز
قارب الاقتصاد المصري اخذه واوجهه ارجع
للكتاب ده ياخذ منه دروس كثيره جدا مظبوط
هذه الفتره الزمنيه ليه لانه
البيئه الحاليه اقتصاديا البيئه غير امنه
كما كانت
في الغام تحت سطح المال ولازم اخد بالي
فيه في جبال جليد غاطسه لازم تاخد تقرا
الخريطه كويس كده
انما حاليا اللي حاصل الاتي انت لا يوجد
نظام نقدي عالمي
منذ ان
فصم نيكسون العلاقه بين الدولار الامريكي
والذهب في اول السبعينات عظيم فاصبح انت
في عالم
اسعار العملات تتقلب صعودا وهبوطا تستخدم
احيانا
للعدوان كما نلاحظ في التعامل
بتاع الغرب بذات مع روسيا والصين
وفي اماكن اخرى دي النقطه الاولى النقطه
التانيه انه لازال بنيه الهيمنه والسيطره
موجوده فيما يسمى ثلاث مؤسسات
ممكن اضيف لها مؤسسه رابعه انما التلات
مؤسسات تسمى مؤسسه الدوليه
بتكلم على صندوق النادي الدولي والبنك
الدولي اللي انس
حوالي خمسين سنه
تحديدا في سنه 94 منظمه التجاره العالميه
وعايز اضيف للتلاته دول
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه لحم
السميه والسعوديه يمكن الناس تستغرب من
تبديل مش دوليه تمارس نفوس جامد جدا في
مساله وضع السياسات
في تعاملات الاطراف الاضعف من نظام الدولي
مع
الادوات الهيمنه اللي هي الصندوق والبنك
ومنظمه التجاره العامه بحكم مركز الولايات
المتحده
المتميز والمسيطر سواء بشكل مباشر او
يباشر على هذه المنظمات المسماه دوليه ده
الوضع
السياق طبعا هو هناك حدث يجري ليس بعيدا
عنه
المعاقده
الاساس في قمه في الواقع
انه بعض المفعول بهم
يريدون التملص والتخلص من
يعني فكرنا عرفت فكره مع الفارق طبعا
بموضوع الفتوى في روايات نجيب محفوظ
واحد يجي يتحدث
هو الفتوى خلاص المساله
فهنا طبعا الواقع انك انت الكل يعيش
ويعاني هيمنه عمله واحده اللي هي الدولار
الامريكي
ويتمنى اليوم اللي يمكن التخلص فيه من شكل
من اشكال العبوديه الاقتصاديه في حقيقه
الامر يعني لانه الولايات المتحده عايشه
على عرق الاخرين هي بتطبع الورق الاخضر ده
وكل الناس بيستخدموا تعمل به كل حاجه مش
امر ربنا انما امر بيكا لما نقرا الايه
الاتفاقيه بتاعه 94
44 44
كويس انك خدت بالك فاذا دي اول شيء ثاني
شيء انت عندك من ادوات الهيمنه
صندوق النقد الدولي والبنك اللي احنا
بنقول عليه مؤسسات بريسون
موجب اطفائيه تمت على ارض السيد الجديد
العالم المتحده
سهل شمال الشرقي للولايات المتح
ده وطبعا الاتفاقيه في اشياء كثيره انما
من وجهه نظر اتفاقيه العالم فريقين فريق
يقرض واخر يقترب
وما على المقترض الا ان ينصع لشروط المخرج
ده نوع من الفكر ولكن ليس الفكر رحيم لانه
اذا قلنا ان دي علاقه
تفاعل يعني انت بتيجي الاموال وانا بستخدم
الاموال مصلحه حينما استخدم الاموال
وبالتالي اذا حصل مشكله من عمليه تبادل
الاموال فلا يجوز ان يحمل بها الطرف
المتلقي بها وحده
في صحيح اذا تكلمنا على مسؤوليه بين
الطرفين لكن الشروط واضحه جدا انه
حصل مشكله يبقى العيب يقع على الطرف
المتلقي المنظمه الثالثه مناظره شديده
الباس والسطوه اللي هي منظمه التجاره
العالميه انا عايز توقف عندها
بعض الشيء باعتبار فلاح انه قبل المنظمه
كان في
وقعت في نفس تاريخ في ادريس
ولكن لان الولايات المتحده لم يرق لها بعض
العناصر
فرفضت ان تنشا منظمه واستمر الامر انت
عندك اتفاق مكتوب بيطبق
انما ابتداء من 95 داخل هذا الاتفاق عايز
التنفيذ والمسؤوله عن تنفيذ المنظمه
التجاري الجديد فيه بقى اساسا
انه
الاولويه للخارجه على حساب الداخل
بمعنى انك انت الداخل يوافق اوضاعه في
دوله ما يعني داخل في مصر الداخل فيه كذا
مثلا هتعمل ايه في الزراعه المصريه بيبقى
في حاجه اسمها السوق العالميه للمنتجات
الزراعيه لابد للسماح بالمنتجات الزراعيه
اللي داخله من الخارج انها تدخل فضاء
مفتوح عولمه وطبعا كما نعرف جميعا الزراعه
ليست مجرد نشاط اقتصادي الزراعه طريقه
حياه
وتحت هذا العنوان بالمناسبه الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بيدعم الزراعه داخل دول الاتحاد بما يعادل
مليار دولار يورو يوميا مليار دولار يوميا
يوميا يوميا في دول الاتحاد
عشان يظل قدر على انتاج ما يحتاجه
احتكامنا الى
الاداه دائما يرفعوها في وشنا اللي هي
المنافسه
والكفاءه
الاوروبي مشكور في زراعيا من وجوه كتيره
ربما القمح محسوله واتنين تاني لكن
بتتكلم على فرنسا زراعه
طريقه حياه فيها تقاليد فيها عرف فيها
تاريخ فيها كل الكلام دوت الامن الغذائي
وفيها الامن الغذائي انما حتى الامن
الغذائي لما تيجي تطرحه في الجزء المفعول
به من العالم بيبقى في جدل يقول لك لا مش
بتنتج ما ياتي لك بالمال وتستورد
احتياجاتك بتاعه عنوان كبير جدا انه
الداخل في دوله كذا وكيته عليه ان يتكيف
الاوضاع ما يسمى السوق العالميه السوق
العالميه دي معناها الدول مهيمنه بس بتسمي
سوق عالميه وكانها بتاعتنا كلنا
ولذلك مثلا من الابداعات اللغويه فكره
التكيف الهيكلي تكافل في جوهره انك انت
تعدي الاوضاع الزراعه واوضاع الصناعه
واوضاع العمل واوضاع
الفقراء والاغنيه كلها في بلدك طبقا
لمقتضيات الوضع تبقى الاحتياجات ومصالح
الدول الكبيره هذا هو جوهر الصراع وانا
رايي انه صراع بدا ولن ينتهي بسهوله خصوصا
بقى وده وجه اخر العولمه ما كان احد ماذا
ياها انه كل انسان في كل مكان اصبح ما
يجري في كل مكان اخر
في حكر
من هذه الزاويه وده معناه انه
في رايي سيخلق قوه الدفع
مع المطالبين بتغيير هذا النظام الظالم
مش معناها انه النتيجه اللي تحصل بكره هو
صراع مرير لانه المكاسب في عاليه جدا انما
عايز اقول ده اللي حاصل عالميا وبالتالي
في النهايه
في جزئين من العالم نحن لا نرى الصوره
بهذا الشكل ولا نرى انك امام بنيه قائمه
على القهر والتحكم لدول المركز بزعامه
الولايات المتحده مره نسميها امريكا مرت
ضيف عليها كم دوله ومجموعه الاربعه مجموعه
السبع مجموعه العشرين خلاص تعدلت الاسماء
والهيمنه واحده
طيب لما اجي بقى
اشوف الوضع عندي داخليا طب هل تاذن لي قبل
حركه تتكلم مع الوضع داخليا الخص
لاصدقائنا واتاكد ان انا فهمت حضرتك انا
اسف اذا كان اللغه متقاعره
عندنا ان انا متعود ان انا انما ما فهمته
من حضرتك انه ان النظام العالمي اللي احنا
عايشينه الان بقياده الولايات المتحده بدا
يتشكل في سنوات مبكره بين الحرب بين
العالميه الاولى والعالميه الثانيه ثم
اكتمل تشكيله في عام 1944 حين اتضحت
الصوره الولايات المتحده هي القوه
المهيمنه بريطانيا العظمى تراجع دورها في
الباكسيد في المقعد الخلفي والنظام
العالمي الجديد ده اللي بتقود الولايات
المتحده قام على مجموعه من المؤسسات ما
زالت تهيمن على العالم زي الصندوق النقد
الدولي البنك الدولي ثم اتفاقيه الجات
اللي تحولت الى منظمه التجاره العالميه
سنه 94 بالاضافه الى الهيئه لحركه اشرت
عليها هيئه الامريكان التنميه الدولية
هيئه المعونه الامريكيه ولها مقرها بالقرب
منك في المعادي في مصر وانما من خلال هذه
الادوات الولايات المتحده بتحكم سيطرتها
على العالم بدعم من حلفائها لكن تحديدا
الولايات المتحده واللي حضرتك بتقول ان
هذه النظام بيقوم على فكره عالمين دول
المركز او الدول المسيطره والدول المهيمن
عليها ونحن كدول ناميه وايمن علينا
الجديد في المساله ان احنا بنمر وفقا
لتعبير الفيلسوف مش احنا هنا كنا عملنا له
حلقه انه ابتكر تعبير لنفس الفكره اللي
حضرتك قلت عليها فكره ان احنا بنعيش فتره
انتقاليه واللطيف انه اشر لنفس الفتره
اللي حضرتك قلت عليها انه كتب الكلام ده
قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقال نحن ما
بين الحرب العالميه الاولى والحرب
العالميه الثانيه نمر بمرحله انتقاليه
النظام القديم يسقط والنظام الجديد لم
يتشكل بعد حضرتك بتقول في الوقت الحالي
هناك النظام القائم للولايات المتحده وفين
دول بتتمرد عليه بقياده الصين ودول انضمت
اليها مثل بريكس بيتمردوا على حمايه
الولايات المتحده ودولارها وفي هذا الاطار
يعيش العالم وتنتج ازماته هذا هو التشخيص
حضرتك مضبوط عظيم جدا طيب اذا انتقلنا من
الازمه الصراع اللي داير بين القوه الكبرى
والدول المهيمن عليها
منها الدول العربيه ومصر الى اخرها تمام
هنا طبعا عايز ابدا بالاشاره الى كثير من
السلوكيات البشر
وقررت الدول بالمناسبه
مبنيه على ما نسميه الصوره الذهنيه انت
تتصور امر ما بطريقه ما
بناء على هذا التصور تبتدي تتصرف
في الاحاله الى وضعنا والمغلوبين على
امرهم كثيرا نقطه البدايه للتغيير انه
يبتدي يرى الاخر اللي هو الدول مهمنه
على حقيقتها بمعنى انه ليس على انه مجموعه
من فعلت الخير
ومجموعه من
الناس الطيبين اللي عايزين يساعدوا
ويعاونوا في مساله مهمه لانه
يسمع الكلام ده مثلا من الحاجات
اللي تستحق ان يتوقف عندها في هذا السياق
وبهذه مناسبه
تعبير عندنا اسمه
شركاء التنميه
الدول الكبيره اللي بتدي معاونات للدول
النائمه شركاء التنميه للصلاح في منتهى
الخطوره
لو انت داخل في علاقه مع طرف ثاني مهيمن
وانت متصور انه ما فيش هيمانع والاحزنون
وان احنا شركاء زي مثلا زوج وزوجه على
سبيل المثال
يبقى في حقيقه الامر عمليا سوف يرتب على
هذا نتائج كثيره خطيره بعضها خطير للرايه
كويس لانه لما بتتكلم على شركاء التنميه
انت الكل بيعنيك ان هو عندك المؤسسه دي
ودي دي بدون ذكر اسامي بتدي لك تمويل وحتى
التمويل برضو في محاوله لتغيير القوس
تساقم مع الصوره ذهنيه ما عدتش بنسميه قرض
بتسميه تمويل الملك من قانون الجديد
القاموس الجديده محتاج ننتبه ليه جدا
فكل التركيز ونصب على انت هتاخد كم مليار
ولا كم مليون
من الاتفاق دوت ماشي مثلا في 2016 خدنا 12
مليار دولار من صندوق نادي الدولي كما
نذكر على حوالي ثلاث سنوات ولكن يعني
الاتفاق ضمان لك انك انت لو نفذت
التعويضات للاخر
طيب ترتب على دقيق في النهايه كلنا عارفين
ترتب عليه
ولو انكر المنكرون انما الواقع بيتكلم لكن
عايز اقول بقى انه على فكره السم في العسل
ان هو بيدي لك تمويل تحت مسمى مساعده قرض
ميسر منحه قرض مش ميسر
ده ده الشق اللي باين للكمال الشق اللي
غير واضح ولكنه اكثر فتكا الشروط غير
الماليه
لمثل هذه الاتفاقات
اما تقرا
نص الدفاع نص الدفاع قرض مثلا خد قرض من
البنك الدولي
لاضافه للصندوق نفس القصه قرض من هيئه
المعونه الامريكيه تجد انه
في عمليه
التفاوض والتوقيع والتنفيذ من جانبنا
الرؤيه هي كده انك انت بتتعامل مع الطرف
التاني على انه منفعلت الخير وبيديك عمله
صعبه وعمله صعبه دي يعني نبوسه ايدينا وش
وظهر وناخدها الموضوع ليس كذلك انا عايز
اقول
لابد ان نتحرر من هذه النظره الى الخارج
على انه له مساعن حميده
يسعى الى فعل الخير ليس له حسابات مائيه
وبالتالي بسميه شريك التنبيه طب هل ممكن
استاذن حضرتك نتكلم على رايك لان دي نقطه
مطروحه ودائما مطروحه نسالك بالتفصيل يعني
انت حضرتك ماذا يعني تنتقده في صندوق
النقد وبرامجه لانه وفق الاقتصاديين كثيره
يقول لك والله هم ما بيقولوش حاجه غريبه
انا هسمع اجابه حضرتك بس عاوز اختم الجزء
ده ثم انتقل الى جزء خاص بصندوق النقد في
حلقه منفصله واسال حضرتك انت حضرتك بتشير
الى ان الدول الكبيره بتمارس ضغوط على
الدول الصغيره من خلال شرط مكتوبه شروط
غير مكتوبه بحيث ان هي لا تنتج لا صناعه
ولا زراعه وتظل دول تابعه انا فاهم حضرتك
واذكر ان حضرتك كتبت وقلت اكتر من مره انك
انت كنت شاهد على ذلك بنفسك حركت وليتي
وزاره مرتين وقبل الوزاره حضرتك كنت
مستشارا يعني ابحاث كثيره
مهام كثيره من البنك الدولي والصنادي هل
ممكن نختم بمثال او اكثر مثالين على حاجه
حضرتك لمستها وشفتها ازاي الدول الكبيره
وهذه المؤسسات بتحاول قمع الزراعه او
الصناعه في الدول الناميه في موضوع يخصنا
يخص الزراعه المصريه ودور
خلينا نسميها هيئه المعونه الامريكيه
هيئه المعونه الامريكيه صرفت 300 مليون
دولار امريكي تقريبا يعني
في تسعينات من القرن الماضي في مشروع بحث
كبير جدا
اسمه
المشروع القومي للبحوث الزراعيه ده
العنوان
وهو شيء يعني
اشترك فيه علماء مصريين وعلاء امريكان
وعلماء اسرائيليين وكان بيستخدم كاداه
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل
انما الاهم بالنسبه لي انا لما تقرا
التفاصيل
والتوصيات اللي انتهت بها هذا البحث اللي
على مدى فتره طويله
وتكلفه
اذا حبيت جمله واحده تفكيك اوصال زراعه
المصريه
طبعا
يعني انت عملت كده فعلا شيء يدعو الانزعاج
وانزعاج شديد كمان بمعنى ايه
احنا علماء الزراعه بيميزوا بين نوعين من
الزراعات او منوال او النسخ الناسخ
الزراعي
المروي
والنسق الزراعي المطري
احنا عندنا نهر مروي عشان امريكا عندها
اساسا اذا استثنيت سهل كاليفورنيا في
الغرب زراعه عندهم مطري كويس كده
معنى مطري انه لما ربنا بيبعت الغيث من
السماء الناس بتزرع وتعيش وبعدين تدور
الدوره والسنه الجايه نفس الحكايه فبيزرع
الارض مره واحده في السنه انت هنا بتزرع
الارض نزرع مرويه في المتوسط مرتين في
السنه نفس الارض
ومعنى هذا الكلام انت تتابع المحاصيل على
الارض لابد ان يدار بعنايه لانه بعض
المحاصيل شديده الاجهاد للتربه
ومعاصيل اخرى شديده الحنيه او
اللطف بالتربه مظبوط تاخد في حالتنا ناخد
حاجتين القطن والبرسيم
وبخلفيتك فلاح دايما بعد القطن لازم نزرع
برسيم عشان يلطف من التربه
ويديها عناصر سحابه منها الايه لان القطن
مجهد للتربه جدا
واحده من التوصيات واخذ بها للاسف الشديد
قالت لها الغي الدوره الزراعيه
الدوره الزراعيه دي معناها الغي تدخل
الدوله في التخطيط والدورات الزراعيه
والاشراف الزراعي المحاصيل وتجميع
المحاصيل في منطقه معينه وكان الحجه والله
الفلاح سيد قراره احنا ما عندناش دوري
زراعيه في امريكا
فكره الصوره الذهنيه هنا مساله مهمه جدا
جدا في الموضوع
قال لك ايضا مش المفروض الدوله لها علاقه
بالبحث والتطوير استنباط سلالات جديده
فيخرج بنك البتاع
مركز البحوث الزراعيه من المجال ده
خرج مركز البحوث الزراعيه المجله واصبح
تعتمد على مين بقى شركات دوليه النشاط
اللي بتنتج
التقاوي والكلام ده
فازاي اعتمادك على الخارج بتنتج حاجات ما
تقدرش تسيطر عليها بتستورد حاجات ما اقدرش
اسيطر عليها ايوه رساله مهمه جدا
بمعنى ايه يعني هو بيستخدم ما يسمى
جينيتك انجنيرنك الهندسه الوراثيه هندسه
الوراثيه الهندسه الوراثيه بينتج اشياء قد
لا تتوافق مع مقاومات البيئه الزراعيه
اللي عندك انت لانه مش كل البيئات
الزراعيه نفس الايه نفس النمط فجيب مثلا
طماطم وتحطها في ينتج عنها مشاكل او تجيب
قمح وتحطه
ادي واحده التالته باختصارا في حاجات
تانيه انا ما قال لك كمان
البنك بتاع التنميه والائتمان الزراعي ده
يتحول الى بنك تجاري
يدي القروض بمنطق تجاري لمنطقه تجاري دعم
المزارعين زي البنك الاهلي وبنك مصر وقد
كان فتعدي القانون والمسمى بتاع البنك
اصبح البنك الزراعي المصري
وزي البنك الاهلي من ناحيه قواعد ممارسه
النشاط وهكذا وبناء عليه كل ده سمع في
نقطه مهمه جدا اللي هو زعزعه الامن
الغذائي لمصر وده تطور خطير
بالمعيار الاستراتيجي وبناء اعزائي كان
بقول انه
علينا ان
ندقق كثيرا في العلاقه مع الخارج وان
نراجع مفاهيم مثل
شركاء التنميه والتمويل وكل هذا الكلام
ونقرض فئات القرود قبل ما نمضي عليها هل
تسلم على الدكتور انا يعني قلت كلام مهم
وفي نفس الوقت طرحت علينا او في اذهاننا
اسئله شديده الاهميه ممكن نطرحها في حلقه
تانيه بعد اذن حضرتك بس عاوز اتاكد من
جمله معنى كده ان هذا النشاط او هذا
التمويل ال 300 مليون دولار اللي عقدوا
ينفقوا فيه التسعينات من هيئه امريكيه
للمعونات بمشاركه علماء امريكان واسرائيل
مصريين ادت الى تدهور الزراعه بشكل كبير
بعد تنفيذها في التسعينات
وادت الى انه الاعتماد اكثر كثير
الزراعه المصريه على التقاوي
والبذور الخارجيه صحيح وفي جمله قللت
ترابط الزراعه المصريه بباقي القطاعات
الاقتصاد في مصر
وزادت من ترابطها بقطاعات الاقساط في
الخارج بحيث تخدم على احتياجات الخارج
ونبقى سوق مفتوح اكتر ما احنا سوق بتكفي
نفسها واظن وقتها يعني انا اسف ان انا
اقتلت انا عاوز اختم علشان ابدا حاجه
تانيه انه اظن في الفتره ديت نشات فكره ان
بلاش نزرع مزروعات
استراتيجيه زي القمح والقطن احنا نعمل
الكنتالوب والفراوله لان ده بيجيب عائد
اكبر وبفلوس هنشتري القمح ونشتري الدره
مظبوط معنا الدكتور واللي حسينا بيه احنا
بقى في الفتره الاخيره بقى ما عندنا اولا
ما عندناش الفلوس ديت مبدئيا يعني لكن
اكتشفنا انه مش سهل ان انت تشتري القمح
ولا الذره
اد امر للمراكب اللي كانت جايبه رئيس سنه
65 وقع مشهوره جدا مراكب كانت في طريقه
شايله قمح لمصر اداها امر ترجع تاني تحاول
الاتجاه بتاعها
ولولا مساعده الاتحاد السوفيتي في ذلك
الوقت كان حصل مشاكل
مع استخدام القمح كالسلاح نتوقف ونستانف
في حلقه مقبله مع الدكتور ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك شكرا جزيلا وشكرا لحضراتكم وان شاء
الله نستانف مع الدكتور جوده
هذه السلسله من الحلقات اللي بتقول لنا
ماذا يجري في العالم وتاثير هيمنه القوه
الكبرى على الدول الناشئه ومنها طبعا دول
العالم العربي اشكركم والى اللقاء